Poland sends troops to the Belarus
border fearing threats from Russia via
its neighbor also has been Central in
helping Ukraine fight the war but
there's been tension too at times just
as with the EU how will the Ukraine War
affect Poland's future this is Inside
Story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program I'm Mr Hill
Rahman Poland has been playing a central
role in the war in Ukraine as a vital
NATO Bridgehead for supplies to its
neighbor and a destination for millions
of refugees since the end of the Soviet
Union relations with Russia have never
been warm the war intensifying enmities
forged over a difficult history
membership of the European Union and
NATO has seen the former Soviet Bloc
country become a major nation in Western
alliances but at times relationships
have been strained and frayed just last
week tensions boiled over in a spat
between Ukraine and Poland with each
calling in the others Ambassador when a
Polish Minister accused Ukraine of
lacking gratitude intervention by
Ukrainian President Vladimir zelenski
was needed to cool things down
well relations between Poland and
neighboring Belarus are seen as being at
an all-time low more polish troops are
being sent to the Border leaders in
Warsaw accuse Minsk of airspace
violations by military helicopter Crews
and say that Russian Wagner group
mercenaries pose a threat Poland was
also angered by Belarus helping African
migrants travel towards a Polish border
and attempt to get into the EU
tensions too surrounding Ukrainian grain
Imports into the EU now Poland imposed
its own grain embargo after Ukrainian
supplies into Europe since the War Began
brought prices down hitting Poland's
vital agricultural sector ahead of a
Polish general election in October there
have been calls to widen the Embargo to
include some fruit and poultry
while United with EU allies over Ukraine
militarily Poland is involved in serious
disputes too the eu's highest court the
European court of justice says polish
changes to how judges are appointed are
illegal the Polish Justice Minister
lashed out calling the European Court
corrupt the EU is also withholding
nearly 40 billion dollars in Aid to
Poland with serious disputes over green
energy policies coal mining and phasing
out vehicles with petrol and diesel
engines their strong Unity however with
the EU over Russia seen as a direct
threat to Poland
there are all kinds of hybrid attacks
right now on our borders on the
Lithuanian border on the Polish border
which we have been seeing for the past
two years Russia and Belarus are
increasing the pressure on our borders
they are increasing the number of
provocations and we have to be aware
that the number of these provocations
will increase
now the Kremlin says Poland is becoming
the most pro-us European power hostile
to Russia
there are existing risks associated with
the militarization of Poland which has
become the main instrument of the United
States anti-russian policy Warsaw
announced its intention to build
according to the polls the most powerful
Army on the continent in this regard
large-scale purchases of weapons have
begun from the United States of America
Great Britain and the Republic of Korea
including tanks artillery systems air
defense and missile defense systems and
combat aircraft me away
[Music]
let's bring in our guests in Warsaw
Liliana snehich the president of the
Warsaw Institute a Polish non-profit
Think Tank specializing in geopolitics
and International in fairs in Berlin is
Ben Harris founder and editor-in-chief
of bne in tele news that is a Business
Media Company focusing on Emerging
Markets but also joining us from
Poland's capital is Mikhail baronovsky a
senior fellow and managing director at
the German martial fund East a
non-profit transatlantic organization a
warm welcome to Inside Story
um Mikhail can I start with you in
Warsaw because Poland is spearheading
the defense of Europe when it comes to
any potential aggression from Russia and
Russia's allies Warsaw accuses Belarus
of allowing russian-backed Wagner troops
a threatening and Advance on its borders
how worried should we be
well this is all depends of what the
Wagner's group will do in Belarus uh for
a number of years we have now considered
Belarus as basically a military space of
Russia uh Belarus is losing sovereignty
uh the Wagner group is coming nuclear
weapons are coming so that is very
worrying and Poland as you said is on
the front
um of this confrontation with with
Russia given that 90 of military aid to
Ukraine goes through Poland and uh and
Poland is becoming a strong NATO Ally
with spending over four percent on
defense this year Ben can I ask you the
same question in Berlin how worried
should we be about the buildup of
Russia's allies you might say on the
Belarus border well certainly uh that
Russia's been using better as a launch
pad for his aggression against Ukraine
and of course in February last year that
it attacked from the north side caught a
lot of people out by coming through
Belarus down to gear that's the short
way of doing it however there's some
reports this morning on a Russian um
telegram channel so Checkers saying that
lukashenko has actually kicked the
Wagner troops out because he's refused
to pay for them uh we're waiting for
confirmation on that story but um again
I think the Wagner troops have unsettled
everyone because after their eight
months campaign to take backwards
they've established themselves a
reputation of being ferocious and
effective Fighters and so having such a
potent military force in Belarus has
unsettled everybody Poland in particular
which I think is partly motivated them
to beat up the troops but again
lukashenko is is a is a bit of a loose
cannon
um the chances of Belarus and him
specifically attacking somewhere like
Poland think are very low but he likes
to mix things up he likes to build up
tensions and which he uses in his
negotiations with Putin in particular he
has to be useful to Putin and keeping uh
on and on his back foot is definitely
useful okay I'll certainly agreeing with
you on that but let's uh cross over to
Liliana also in Warsaw uh is it a
nervous time for the the thinkers in
Warsaw the politicians the critics the
supporters to try and work out what's
going on on Poland's borders how do you
assess the situation at the moment
especially when there is this talk of a
buildup of troops potentially on the
Poland Belarus border
yes uh first of all thank you very much
for the invitation and directly
answering your question well of course
the situation is very serious however on
the other hand uh well Russia was also
supposed to get Kiev in seven days so we
need to think about it as a reality
however yes the situation is very very
um difficult also Poland is spending a
lot of money on defense
also investing in not just International
military equipment but also on our
domestic one so yes the situation is
serious however we also need to be
realistic
and of course uh Liliana before I go
back to uh Mikhail about this how do
people assess Poland's membership of
NATO do they think it's working in this
particular context of other NATO
countries also helping Poland defend its
borders
well I would say that NATO is our
security guarantor and I believe
ability of society would agree with me
so there's no doubt that the this two
percent uh that we need to spend on our
defense is just the minimum and also
Poland is encouraging other countries to
spend even more
can I come to you in Warsaw in your
opinion the Russian tactics are changing
aren't they uh when it comes not just to
Wagner but the relationship with Belarus
and with lukashenko
um their friends their allies
Wagner is there one minute then there's
this talk of nuclear weapons how strong
is the relationship and where are the
weak points in that relationship
well let me first uh just agree with
Ileana about uh NATO's popularity in
Poland just just so everyone knows
Poland is in fact our NATO is uh Poland
is the most Pro NATO country that that
we have in Europe uh gmf will come out
soon with Paul showing this as well so
there is no question about the
popularity of of NATO
um in in Poland and when we look to
Belarus and Russia again especially the
Strategic Community the thinkers the
military the politicians are seeing
basically a connected space yes
wukashenka is there yes he is the
president of of Belarus but because of
his crimes against his own people
because of his economic dependence on
Russia and now because of presence of a
Wagner group and nuclear weapons on his
territory we really should not consider
Belarus a separate sovereign country
Putin could get rid of wukashenko if he
really wants to
main goal is to remain in power because
that guarantees that he is staying alive
so it
it's no longer any possibility for for
wukashenko and Belarus to balance in any
ways Russia and and the West it's firmly
within the grip of Moscow and that's why
when we see Maneuvers close to our
borders in Poland this is when we get
concerned especially about the hybrid
tactics indeed let's come to you in
Berlin because it's interesting the
perspective from Poland to where you are
in Berlin the Germans will have a very
different take on it but obviously you
know your news agency that looks the
whole whole of Europe as one as such I
mean what's the perspective there about
what's going on between the Poland and
belarussian border
in this Europe has been divided and that
border was open before insta matches
before the war war there was a huge
amount of trade between the European
Union and Russia until the sanctions
started to appear in 2014 and that
border was wide open and most of the
traffic there was a constantly a queue
of trucks Crossing it one way or the
other
I must change now is we have a fortified
border it's become a militarized border
um in so much as Lithuania also shares a
short border with uh Belarus and it's
recently closed two of its posts over
the last eight months the ukrainians
have massively fortified their part of
the Border in order to stop a second
invasion from the north you know
threatening Kiev and now we're seeing
that uh Poland is seen this incursion
with the helicopters last week which
shook everyone up the threat of Wagner
troops being in in battle Russia has
unsettled people and now uh Poland is
also militarizing their part of the
border and if you remember about a year
ago there was the migrant crisis where
uh lukashenko was sending thousands of
you know largely Middle Eastern uh
refugees across the border and again it
was just open I mean people were
wandering through the forest and and
that's changed I mean there's now barbed
wire fences and they cleared part of the
forest in front of the fence and there's
serious guards there and we haven't seen
that kind of militarized border in
Europe for whatever it's seven to
sometimes yeah and it's returned
um
yeah I mean several there are several
issues that Poland's going through at
the moment and one obviously is this
issue with uh Ukraine and the war in
Ukraine uh set about by by Russia let's
just slightly move on to uh the
relationship of Poland uh and the war
and Ukraine
um you know it to the outside world it
seems a very cozy relationship that both
Ukraine and Poland have uh but there are
issues uh between Poland and the rest of
Europe on a different front uh with the
EU and the court of justice Liliana can
I come to you about this and about uh
jurisdiction about sovereignty about who
really is in charge of Poland because
when you have that ingrained you might
say or set in stone only then can Poland
deal with its neighbors and its
International Partners this has not been
resolved has it between
Warsaw and Brussels
well indeed I would say that the
relationship between as you said Warsaw
and Brussels is quite complicated uh
however
um the um
this this crisis this problem in
Judiciary System as you also mentioned
has I would say two Dimensions first of
all is the political and also the
substantive level so yes I agree the
Judiciary System yes still needs some
reforms and we can also hear from some
of the representatives of government
that actually there are some plans to
reform it if they will win their third
currency but there's also another
component of it which is a political uh
Dimension uh even you know just last
year when Ursula from The Lion visited a
war so she had a meeting with with our
prime minister moravitsky and it seems
like the conflict was resolved and
probably the next general generation
fund will come to Poland however it
didn't happen so I believe that till the
law Injustice is in power it is possible
that Poland will not get the money from
uh from the Next Generation fund indeed
uh can I come to you in water this is a
good an issue that is grinding on as
Poland heads towards a general election
and yet some analysts and if you you
know read what's on the internet and the
people that we're speaking to at Al
Jazeera about this the uh the incumbent
political party has been very good at
demonizing its opposition and demonizing
minority groups all in the space of
saying this is for National sovereignty
and National Security
uh yes indeed that that is the argument
but it is uh very firmly rejected by all
the European and in fact broader than
European uh legal authorities there is
really no standing that on the issue
that the changes that the government
introduced in the uh in the legal system
um fall within the rule of law as as uh
as other European
countries have there is you know the the
issue and this conflict has been uh
almost resolved as Liliana pointed out
but uh but it was in fact president Duda
who didn't sign the law President coming
also from Law And Justice put it inside
and signed the law that would correct
some of the biggest issues with uh with
uh rule of law so I think there is a
there is a relatively little expect
education that if Law And Justice wins
the upcoming parliamentary election on
October 15th that it will be death camp
that fixes the issues of rule of law I
think that our expectations that Poland
can begin to a longer process in fact of
going back to uh Judiciary System that
has a level of Independence uh only
under a different government than the
current one what that happens a lot well
here's what we start to wait and see I
mean Ben Harris in Berlin that President
Biden was actually in Poland earlier in
the year
um you know espousing or extolling the
virtues of freedom and democracy
um around the anniversary of the
invasion of Ukraine it all sort of fell
at the right time you might say but it
says uncomfortably doesn't it with the
us having to make alliances
as some might see with countries that
have rather questionable
um I wouldn't say domestic internal
politics and issues over human rights
you know it's not just Poland it's
turkey in India as well
indeed I mean we have been covered the
entire region and we see this in a
regional context and I think Biden had
to go there and give that message
because Poland needed reminding about
the Democracy part I mean the the
judicial reforms are effectively giving
the the government the the ruling party
uh a tool whereby they can pressure the
courts which is you're supposed to have
separation of you know the the Judiciary
and the government and the Gallup did a
very interesting poll several years ago
and found that there's a uh a a values
fault line that runs down the middle of
Europe and although Poland's bought into
the European union membership because
economically it's worked fantastically
well and so much as Poland gets some
nine billion euros a year in
reconstruction funds and to put that in
context you know before the war Ukraine
used to get three billion so it's a lot
of money and Poland has flourished in
2008 is the only country in Europe that
didn't go into recession but they
haven't really bought into the values
part of the EU project
and again this fault line of values if
you look to the uh to the east pollens
on that side and it adheres to these
more sort of traditional in its case
Catholic um conservative values and the
rest of Eastern Europe Orthodox
conservative values where family is the
most important
um where it's a much more sort of
authoritarian top-down kind of uh
Administration rather than the liberal
democracy that we have here in Germany
for example and and that's actually a
problem it's a work in process and they
haven't
yeah Liliana you want to come in there
uh yes well I disagree with some parts
of your speech because uh you're talking
that we didn't imply you know European
values I wouldn't use this kind of word
because Poland welcome millions of
refugees and it is a world phenomenon
because we didn't create any of the
refugee camps as for example Germany did
but we welcome all of the refugees to
our houses so we gave our hearts to to
refugees and I wouldn't say that we
didn't imply European values because
European values is for example
solidarity and that's what Poland
exactly showed not just the political
Elites but the whole society well
thinking of that Let's cross back to
Mikhail in Warsaw and of course you know
while sort of the global Community looks
at Poland's reputation right now as you
know Heroes and the vocal support and
the military support they're giving to
Ukraine there are underlying tensions
between the two countries that have been
there for many many years hundreds of
years if not um you know one man's hero
such as Bandera for Ukraine is nothing
more than a monster for Poland and these
issues rumble on do they not and this is
why even president zielinski had to get
involved recently
you're absolutely right that Poland and
Ukraine have very difficult history
and we have just had an 80th anniversary
of Boeing Massacre uh where lots of
polls as well as ukrainians have lost
their life but the war brought nothing
less than
almost a miracle I would say in terms of
the depth of Polish Ukrainian
reconciliation as Liliana pointed out a
Polish Society welcomed a Ukrainian War
refugees to our homes
and that history has really become a
history it echoes from time to time but
I cannot imagine us going back to the
difficult political relations caused by
history that we have seen before the war
again the depth of the reconciliation
between our two countries is
irreversible and nothing that I would
expect two years ago before the Before
the War started so history might not be
echoing in the same way that what's
happening is resonating right now
Liliana in terms of the grain deal
because there is friction between
Ukraine and Poland over cheap Ukrainian
grain heading through Poland and to the
European markets and that's upsetting
Poland and its agricultural finances and
belt I mean how is this all going down
at the moment because Poland has
embargoed uh Ukrainian grain certainly
until mid-september that may continue
and that might upset the EU
well uh I would say it's not just a
problem of Poland but all of the eastern
central eastern European countries
because our main branch of the economy
is indeed Agriculture and yes indeed the
farmers were quite upset because of the
lower prices of the Ukrainian grain so
yes in this case the interest of
producers has won over the interest of
consumers however I believe that we'll
need we will need in the future if not
now some kind of interference of the
European commission to solve the issue
especially if we are thinking about the
future accession of Ukraine in the
European Union Bank can I bring you in
from Berlin how much does an issue like
grain imports impact on domestic
politics it's certainly when you're
heading towards a general election and
this is a Hot Topic at the moment in
Poland exactly this is a very
interesting topic and it says quite a
lot about the complicated and difficult
um relations everyone has here in so
much as Ukraine now is completely almost
almost completely bankrupt and it's only
hard currency earner is the grain
exports and with the naval blockade in
the Black Sea and the collapse of the
grain deal that it's been trying to get
as much grain as it can out by train
going west which arrives on the Polish
markets and as Liliana said that
collapsed the local market and upset the
local farmers and so the government in
in Poland
um banned it blocked but this is Poland
Ukraine's biggest supporter and yet at
the same time they've cut them off from
the only source of money that they can
earn at the moment in trade and the
reason why is obvious is because the
election's coming up and the
agricultural Lobby is extremely big and
powerful so hold on let's be forced to
make a change a choice between
supporting his ally
um Ukraine and dealing with domestic
issues winning an election and and it at
the end shows its own um its own agenda
it's its elections uh and now she's hurt
Ukraine to the point where the
ukrainians banned sugar exports to
Poland which again Poland is a big uh
importer of Ukrainian sugar and that
caused a problem the solution
um Poland's asked the EU for a billion
dollars in compensation so I think
that's what's going to happen is throw
some money at it but it and you know
underpins the the western or Western
Europe wants to support Ukraine but at
the same time it needs or wants to limit
the amount of economic damage that's
been done to his own economies
um and so this war can't go on for too
long because it's already costing Europe
a lot of money but as both Mikhail and
Liliana said that Poland in particular
has shown a lot of solidarity and the
rest of Europe has been prepared to take
a lot of pain for the sake of Ukraine um
and that that's European value of that
sense
so let me just jump in with Mikhail just
ask him then how important is it to try
and restart the grain deal and try and
get you might say Russia on Board
address Russia's concerns that its
products weren't being sold
internationally and that it also
questioned whether the grain that was
leaving Ukraine was going to poorer
Nations around the world it really did
question that what's your take on the
way that subject is being discussed in
Poland
well Russia's Naval blockade of the
Black Sea obviously causes huge uh
repercussions in uh throughout the
global South especially when it comes to
hunger uh and and that could be really
fixed easily by President Putin just
signing the the grain deal again
um some of this grain can be transported
through pollen through Romania but it
will not replace the parts of the of the
Black Sea so here the responsibility for
the Hunger just lies very clearly with
Vladimir Putin I do think that we'll
need to find a longer term solution
because Ukraine's agriculture policy
agriculture sector is so large that it
would require a huge changes to the
European agricultural policy
it will when Ukraine will become an EU
member so this is something that will be
grappling with for the for the years to
come certainly throughout the EU well we
all come to the end of our program so
Liliana I'll ask you the last question
in terms of the relationship now between
Poland and Ukraine and Poland and the EU
in your opinion what is of most value
right now to Poland as politicians
so you might say sell their political
position as they head towards that
general election in the Autumn this is
all going to ramp up as the weeks
progress
well I would say that the relationship
of Poland and EU and relationship
between Poland and Ukraine are
completely different things relationship
between Poland and Ukraine is strong and
it will be strong Poland will be
supporting Ukraine it is supporting
Ukraine it will not stop our
relationship with EU is something
completely different so I wouldn't even
bind those two things because
Ukraine's Independence Ukraine
sovereignty is also our goal
interesting conversation I'm sure we'll
be revisiting again in the coming months
it's been great to have you on this
edition of Inside Story Liliana snitch
Ben Aries and Michal barnovsky thank you
for joining me for inside the story and
thank you as well for watching this
Edition you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website at Al
jazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our Facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash AJ Inside
Story now you can also join the
conversation on Twitter my handle there
is ADD AJ inside story from me Sil Ramen
and the whole team here thanks for your
time and your company
[Music]
foreign